my name is Kara zor-el 24 years ago my
planet was in peril
my cousin kal-el was sent to a planet
called Earth you may know his story but
you don't know mine on earth you will do
extraordinary things until now you must
go I love you car
Sorry Sorry
I'm calling about the Correspondents
Dinner I need to make sure miss grant
doesn't end up next to Bill O'Reilly
again hey um I was wondering if maybe
you want to go see a movie tonight
I can't I'm sorry I have a date
Hey hmm fine dating is fun she's here
how'd he do that
the only reason I bought this building
was because it had a private elevator
that way I don't have to get soaked in
cheap cologne every morning getting to
my office find out who used it have them
reprimanded or bathed I don't care with
mr. Watts a hot Oh that'll be new and
different hello I've seen this picture
you won a Pulitzer yeah only because it
was the first real shot of a little
secret you actually posed for that guess
she likes me oh my god you're Jimmy
Olsen photographer good in the day we
bought it James Olsen I never got for me
gosh hi I am Cara Wow
I have a conference in Geneva and I need
to be on a plane in two hours I have a
blind date and a half an hour and I need
you to help me pick out what to wear why
do you do this to me because I'm your
sister and you love me I feel like I'm
not living up to my potential
I just fetched layouts and coffee you
always want it to be normal this is what
normal looks like I'm not normal I can
lift a bus stop a bullet Alex I can fly
at least I think I can by 2:37 bound for
Geneva is circling the city after an
engine failure did he say Geneva
just lost another engine
you're going down brace for impact
No
who is the mystery flying woman who
saved the plane you exposed yourself
you're out there now Kara everyone will
know about you and you can't take that
back I don't want to media magnate cat
grant up national city's new female hero
Supergirl
we can't name her that we didn't
shouldn't you be called super woman what
do you think is so bad about girl I'm a
girl and your boss and powerful and rich
and hot and smart so if you perceive
Supergirl is anything less than
excellent isn't the real problem you
gara I'm going to tell you something
about me that for most of my life I've
run from it but last night I embraced
Who I am and I don't want to stop oh my
god you're lesbian Oh Karl that's why
you're not into me this just this is
this just great news are you okay I'm
her the woman who saved the plane okay
right now what are you doing Hey
you're her yep
I'm not flying around saving people in
this thing where's my cape capes are
lame tell you cousin I said so actually
never never do that
mmm so to be a superhero you need a
crime there's a car chase on the 112
freeway I could do a car chase
Kate aids with aerodynamics I should
have thought of that national suspect if
you share your bulletproof hope so
all right the new Cape is made from
structured polymer composite it's much
sturdier thin and uh this one has the s4
super just like a cousin it's not nests
it's my family's coat of arms the house
of L welcome to the Department of
extra-normal operations the EEO monitors
and protects Earth from extraterrestrial
presence
these beings some of them are powers
from your darkest nightmares I can help
you stop them
I don't trust aliens you want to help go
back to getting someone's coffee Cara
it's me I know what you're thinking but
the world needs you to fly and so do I
so what do we do now first things first
you need to change this ISM I didn't
travel 2,000 light-years just to be an
assistant people of this city will die
have to let me stop it make sure you win
my cousin wanted me to do this how did
he just tell me because he wanted you to
choose it for yourself
same way he did hear from him
that's the blanket he was wrapped in
when he was a baby
apparently this Cape won't read thank
you now don't you have a city to protect
you know up up and away hey youtubers is
Charlie so there's gonna be a breakdown
of the Supergirl footage I know you have
a lot of questions about when it's going
to air how it's going to tie in with the
other DC TV shows so I'll try to answer
all those questions right off the bat if
this looks like the flash and arrow
that's because it's made by the same
people that make the flash and arrow CBS
and CW are owned by the same company
Greg Berlanti Productions produces all
the stuff there's rumors that there is a
clause in his Supergirl contract that
they had to allow it to crossover with
their in the flash that's not confirmed
so don't plan on a whole lot of season 1
crossovers but it's a lot easier for
them to cross this over with the other
shows than it is for the other DC TV
shows the reason why they're probably
doing this back story I mean everybody
knows Superman's backstory we've seen it
a thousand times but not everybody
understands that kara is his cousin and
that she also came from Krypton CBS as a
network isn't necessarily known for
superhero shows so most of its audience
probably aren't really familiar with how
she's different from Superman this is
actually a nice shot of Superman
everyone wonders if he's going to be in
the pilot he'll have brief cameos like
you know we see a lot of references to
him Jimmy Olsen talks about working with
him Superman exists in this universe but
I don't know how much we'll see him you
know Dean Cain is not playing Superman
as you can see to Helen Slater is not
playing her mother like a lot of people
thought she might she actually played
Superman's mother on the Smallville TV
series and just in general you can
actually you can think of this TV show
as what Smallville could have been when
the series picks up she'll be out of
school like fresh out of school in
National City this isn't Metropolis
where she's at
she'll be working for cat grant played
by Calista Flockhart which i think is
kind of funny she'll be like the funny
villain in the series not the real
villain but an antagonist to Kara
Danvers that's her alter ego that's like
her Clark Kent
the real overarching villain to the
series is actually going to be Hank
Henshaw although as we see him she's
actually working with him so it might be
one of those Harrison wells a Bart
Thawne situations for those that have
been watching the flash as in someone
who treats her like a friend but is
secretly working against her I do like
the Clark Kent vibe she's giving off
like total klutz it's a little more
authentic to her character she knows
about her powers but as you saw in the
trailer like she's still kind of
figuring them out like she doesn't know
that
she's bulletproof so imagine like a
sped-up version of Smallville seasons 9
and 10 when Clark was like really
figuring his powers out like learning
new abilities here's where things get
really interesting this character is
actually Toyman from the comics he's a
tech expert at Catco working with Kara
Danvers Catco is like the name of the
company they work at Toyman is a very
famous Superman villain but here in the
trailer he seems like her friend so this
is one of those situations where you
have a really big character with the
potential that they could turn into a
villain in a future season that's one of
the things I feel like the flash is done
really well it's introduced characters
like Caitlin snow who are villains in
the comics but are friendly on the TV
show it just gives them more room to
develop characters over time I like that
he helps her workshop her powers and her
costume I know it seems like he has a
total boner for her in the trailer but
her boyfriend in the series will be
Jimmy Olsen he's being played by Mehcad
Brooks so you might recognize the cool
thing about him in the series is is that
he's already worked with Superman
so he'll be more of a genuine adviser to
her someone for her to confide in to who
you know probably will not turn into a
villain in the future you have to have
at least a few characters you know you
can count on to be good people Jimmy
Olsen of course just gonna be one of
those I like the way he communicates
Superman's ideas for Kara he wanted you
to become this but he wanted you to
choose it just like he did
this is Kara's adoptive sister obviously
Supergirl was adopted just like Superman
was adopted in the context of the series
she's playing a doctor working for Hank
Henshaw most people probably know her as
a doctor from Grey's Anatomy which i
think is kind of funny then we have the
man himself
this is Hank Henshaw most of you know
him as the cyborg superman just pumped
the brakes on the theories because this
is season 1 I think what we might see is
him gradually take on aspects of his
comic-book persona what might happen
here is they might turn into enemies
over time like over the course of a
couple seasons David Harewood just like
Tom Cavanagh in the flash is an amazing
actor so I'm hoping actually both those
series don't lose those characters so
what we're probably going to see in the
pilot episode is her workshop the
costume workshop or powers introduce all
the main characters and convey what the
arc of the season is going to be the
main villain of the pilot is going to be
this alien here he's called vartox
just like an alien convict that's been
hiding out once Supergirl comes out in
public as Supergirl he'll try to destroy
her but there's a lot we don't know
about the narrative that yet just that
he will be the big bad of the pilot but
not of the overarching series if you
remember the flash episode one think of
him is like weather wizard from that so
you guys can let me know like what are
you most excited about for Supergirl I
just I love how much it looks like the
flash really fun with a lot of comedy
and some great special effects it's on
CBS so the good thing is is they
probably have a little bit more money in
their production budget it was picked up
for a full series but the rumor is is
that they had a short in the run just a
little bit to fit it all into their
production schedule so there might only
be like 20 episodes they have it they
haven't confirmed that yet it's going to
premiere in November they don't have an
exact date yet I know that seems kind of
late in the year the prior some more
news about that by the time I post my
next Supergirl bonus video so don't
worry I'll just I'll post an update as
soon as they announce something just to
reiterate though in terms of tone like
what this series is going to look like
think of it is like the most awesome
version of Smallville you could imagine
with the tone of the flash so I'll be
doing tons more Supergirl videos as we
move into the summer bonus video season
be sure to subscribe to get everything
if there's anything specifically any
comic book related stuff you guys want
me to do just let me know in case you
guys haven't seen it I did a video that
talks a little bit about her back story
in the comics you can click here to
watch that and you can click here to
watch my arrow finale video I'll post
that later tonight thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you